hey everyone i'm james marsden I play
Tom hey how are you James Martin from
enchanted I play Sonic the Hedgehog and
we are about to play which Sonic the
Hedgehog character are you I'm also in
West world and a bunch of different TV
shows I work a lot love watches and
racecars here we go
what is your defining characteristic
we have curious intelligent loyal
determined mysterious and calm defining
characteristic I'm not good at talking
about myself curiously what would you be
the intelligent yes but there's you
years and you look you go tist achill no
no it's just being honest I'm gonna pick
loyal I'm pretty loyal that's too loyal
choose a video game powerup you can use
in real life infinite lives invisibility
for shield coins super strength super
speed can't really use coins anymore I
think I'm gonna be obsolete stone I see
a super speed we love that I'm gonna go
super speed can I tell you something
there's a part of me that wants a
infinite lies but then I would never you
die you have to there has to be death
right there's gotta be yin and yang
there has to be a beginning and an end
and and you have all these families that
wouldn't have infinite lives it would be
friends that would perish Wow
otherwise do you would value nothing I
think SuperSpeed is great I'll do it too
she's an iconic video game this seems
geared towards me there's one that says
Chanukah boy is that a video game there
had heard of that before
she's an iconic video you got pac-man
the sim Super Mario Brothers Grand Theft
Auto Frogger Mortal Kombat
I'm gonna have out of these choices I'm
gonna say Super Mario Brothers because I
said Mario you see Mario I said Mario is
one of me Super Mario Brothers because
it's just like me and my brother hanging
out I know but that's the one that I
would choose to or it would be the thing
I've never played The Sims it would be
fine it's like playing away right which
was not fun to me she was another iconic
blue character and you have mystique
from x-men
stitch from Lilo & Stitch Sully Cookie
Monster Dori and Jeannie it's one of
true for me
okay I'm too busy counting the movies
that I was also in your race I was an
x-men right in every this is okay I'm
happy we're here with BuzzFeed anytime
we do a movie somehow it comes out that
he's Cyclops an ex it's not every tab
Bree sing that it will they'll be like
okay so like what was your experience on
the movie oh that's better
no I played a superhero before you know
it's either Genie or Cookie Monster for
me and it's very hard for me not to be
mostly stop looking at what we choose I
know it's later oh I do okay sorry right
sir I did Sully from monsters David yeah
I could see you as a jogger like him I'm
sort of a bigger guy you know something
you see yourself yeah kind of rugged oh
really
uh funny you know Wow having a perfect
boil and devoted Wow perfect human yeah
I guess so place I drops me like cookie
I guess well you're a perfect man you
like live in a way you don't live in the
garbage no that's Oscar that's Oscar but
I'm still all I do is eating cookies but
none of the cookies go actually into my
system I just got my my my my and they
go everywhere oh that's right what's my
number one weakness
caffeine sleep shopping social media at
loud noises and out loud noises human
interaction week there's weaknesses that
are like good weaknesses and like or bad
weakness right because he was playing
Cyclops I would say a weakness of yours
is that you had the ability to shoot
these lasers out of your eyes right I
was gonna say Krypton I have a Superman
but which I was also in that film as
well but but concerned x-men works too
no weakness I wish I was on social media
less I might say social media I wish I
was on it more
really yeah I'm terrible at it I'm
terrible I post something and my numbers
go down oh wow this is that bad you're
like oh I still follow that guy I'm out
I'm gonna go caffeine theory how do you
fight off your enemies you bribe them
with something they want or I give them
an x-men DVD man literally every
question you brought up I'll make it
about everything so how does Cyclops
shoot that readout of you guys what is
that really just opens his eyes it's a
concussive beam of force they could
punch okay all right okay okay so
mountain with a K yes
I've read a lot of comics I don't
remember a mountain no you bribed them
you outsmart them you fight them you
ignore them you appease them you ask
your friends growing up if not enemies
but to feel included out try to be funny
or comedic I picked you appease them
because if I had maybe I'm gonna make
them laugh oh I'll kill them with
kindness I'd appease them right off your
enemies by appeasing them that's doesn't
say a lot about me finally pick
something super fast
two days shipping venmo transaction
high-speed Internet a sports car at
power not yet requesting a rideshare
cyclops and his super bike are you
serious it's right here an option I'm
wearing I'm telling you there is not an
option that says Cyclops and his super
my super girly I do a lot of what was it
like on the set of x-men I cannot
believe we're doing this
what was it like on the set of x-men oh
it was pretty cool I practical effects
I'm just one big family actually very
much so uncomfortable to cost and I've
never been a superhero
alright you are now your sonic banger
man I needed that for me
I don't sleep as much as I want to so
I'm gonna say a powernet good I'm gonna
go sports Kirk we are both knuckles at
times people get in Tulsa your fur but
for the most part you're cool calm and
collected there's ever a crisis people
turn to you because of your calming
energy you wish you could be Cyclops but
in the end your knuckles Cyclops on the
other end is a cool guy brilliant
brilliant actor really handsome admit
have you seen that super bike that's
pretty dang cool pretty incredible
BuzzFeed baby I'm gonna retake this and
try to be sad
oh that's your social security money
AOL calm
good hey tell me I don't know my boy huh
I retook the quiz and got my boy I know
my schmoops BuzzFeed thank you so much
for having us James Marcin from the
notebook and and I am James Marsden from
x-men
I played Cyclops
you